take accountability for your actions
you can take all the credit in the world
for the things that you do right
as long as you also take responsibility
for the things you do wrong hesitation
is the enemy
and in war
understanding where the enemy is allows
you to defeat him
raising standards come from when you
would normally quit
you go one more wanna be happy build a
life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how you can stick
to your habits
even if you're lazy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make smaller goals with jordan
peterson
life is difficult and it's harder to do
things than not to do them and it's
harder to do them well than to do them
badly
you know and it's easy to sit around and
be hopeless i don't mean it's
emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and
to fall back into your old habits and to
not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice
and i think a good example of that is
something like weight lifting you know
if you start a weight lifting program
which i would recommend by the way
because
it it's tremendously advantageous
physically
and cognitively you're not going to
really see results for a number of weeks
and then the results are rather slow but
you can get pretty decent results over a
six-month period and absolutely stellar
results over a couple of years and so
you have to make sure your time frame is
right and not to be too hard on yourself
and
i did mention the future authoring
program
um earlier and one of the things i would
recommend too is if you're having a hard
time
implementing your your decisions say
your ethical decisions
that you spend a bit more time thinking
them through and writing them down and
the future i think program is really
helpful for that that's why we designed
it
and so get your goals straight and
continue to practice
every day and if you're not succeeding
then make your goals slightly smaller
you want to you want to make your goals
large enough
so that they challenge you but small
enough so that you have a reasonable
probability of succeeding at them on a
day-to-day
basis and then you have to also
understand that if you fail on a given
day
like let's say you're trying to quit
smoking and you quit for two weeks and
then you have a cigarette and you think
oh my god now i've screwed it up i've
i'm not quitting anymore you smoke a
whole pack of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed
it just means that you had a cigarette
you can start stopping again the next
day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be realistically
humble
you've got to be ambitious enough in
your goals so that you're pursuing
something that you regard as
truly meaningful and worthwhile you know
and
maybe you can judge that to some degree
if you think about someone you love
attempting the same thing and think
about how you would feel if they managed
it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good um
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
rule number two
keep promises with mel robbins the only
thing that matters when it comes to
changing your life
is can you keep a promise to yourself
can you keep a promise to yourself when
it feels uncomfortable
can you keep a promise to yourself when
suddenly you don't want to
can you keep a promise to yourself when
it'd be easier not to
that is the core skill that you need to
change any area of your life
because change doesn't require
motivation it requires
discipline you need the discipline
to do what you said you were going to do
and i want you to think about this
when you set an alarm setting an alarm
the night before
is an act of making a promise to
yourself
setting alarm which i do i get up
between
6 15 and 6 45
every day i am making a promise to
myself
that i am going to get up when that
alarm rings
and if i can't keep a promise to myself
because i don't feel like it i'm cranky
i'm not a morning
very thin whatever the hell your excuses
you're not going to be able to keep
promises to yourself in any area of your
life
where you feel uncomfortable where it's
easier to avoid conflict
where you succumb to your excuses where
you soothe yourself
instead of pushing through and i mean
this
all change happens the same way
with discipline all change begins with a
decision
to change all change begins with making
and keeping promises so regardless of
what you're working on
if you're working on boundaries if
you're working on saying no
if you're working on pushing yourself
through discomfort
you can start to practice the skill of
showing up for yourself
no matter what by simply setting the
alarm the night before for the when the
time you actually need to get up
and when that time comes and that alarm
rings
and it's time to keep that promise no
matter what you're feeling
your number one job is to keep that
promise to yourself
you start to practice this skill of
setting the alarm
and looking at it as a promise that
you're making to yourself
and when that alarm rings not succumbing
to your excuses or your feelings of
discomfort
but actually getting up and keeping that
promise you start to do that your whole
life will change
and the reason why is all change is
the same it's about making and keeping
small promises
and the more that you do it in one area
of your life the
easier it's going to be for you to do it
in any other area of your life
trust me it's exactly how i've changed
my life
i started here alarm rings get out of
bed
rule number three create new
affirmations with john
ashraf when you want to override
automatic negative thoughts or
disempowering
you know beliefs or self-image
issues the first thing you want to do
from a brain
perspective is first acknowledge
that hey i have this disempowering
thought or disempowering
image a self-image for disempowering
fear i acknowledge that that's okay
so the first thing you do is you don't
pretend it doesn't exist because your
brain knows it exists you notice that
the dog knows
it exists but when you take that
and say yes that's true and now i'm
going to create a
new vision for what i want
to feel i'm going to create a new vision
for how i want to see myself
i'm going to create a new vision to
see myself at the level above the level
that i'm at right now
and you create an image and write it
down
and then what you can do is you can
create a new powerful
declaration or affirmation that goes
like this you may want to write this
down okay
and this is just the beginning process
of retraining your brain there's there's
six different steps that you can do here
i'll give you two of them
so you create a declaration and you say
even though
i feel or even though i have this belief
of what i am focusing on
now is my augmented self-worth or
self-esteem what i'm focusing on now
is getting smarter wiser what i'm
focusing on
now is releasing this fear and stepping
into my confidence and my certainty
now a simple little declaration
of acceptance and then moving towards
what you want
that starts to activate a new neural
pattern so you don't have to
lie to yourself and say you know um
for example is if you feel like you're
not smart enough not
worthy um not capable
and you say you know in the past i have
felt
that i wasn't smart enough not worthy
not capable
and now i'm learning how to if you could
just create a bridge
from the disempowering thought or belief
or emotion or behavior and you can
create a bridge to where the next step
is and now i'm learning how to
and now i'm taking steps towards when
you give yourself
that bridge your brain goes okay you can
do this
so if you don't want to go from i'm not
smart enough to i'm really smart and i
could achieve it for some people that's
too big of a jump
so create a bridge between those two
so that you reduce the neural tension
and you're nice
to your brain and that is one of the
ways that you can do that
hey this is john asref and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much wisdom
in books you get to take somebody else's
knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be
and one of my new friends really smart
guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something
you just haven't found it yet or you
have and you don't
believe in yourself enough to go
all in to go all in right
and you're a genius i believe you're a
genius and so does he
you're amazing you were not meant to
live a photocopy
of someone else's life you were not
created to wake up and do work that is
below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star rule number four lie
cheat and steal with marissa pierre your
mind
always does what it thinks you want when
you say it would kill me
if i were open to business and it failed
it would kill me if i put all my money
in this product nobody bought you and i
guess don't do it
procrastinate and now you have to
understand how to dialogue with you
wondering this is what you do you go i
want this i want it i want it i want it
i have chosen it chosen it chosen it
and i have chosen to feel great about it
those two sentences i've chosen to do
this and chosen to feel great about it
and i want this want this one this will
change your mind so you probably know
that
25 percent of people who buy a
membership to a gym
never go they plan do they intend you
and they just don't go maybe they go
once or twice
then they don't go again so you've got a
gym membership
maybe you've got the dvd in your living
room maybe you've got the exercise rope
and the exercise ball
and diner bands they're all there and
you're not doing it
so how can you make yourself do it first
of all you've got i want to work out i
love working out i feel so great when
i'm working out
i've chosen to work out and chosen to
love it
love it love it and that will get you to
the gym and then when you're
on the machines in the class say it
again i love this
i love it love it love it want it want
it want it i've
chosen this and chosen to feel great you
see your mind
really has no idea whether what you're
telling it is
right or wrong true or false good or bad
i used to work with very overweight
celebrities i take them training with
marines
and they mean to be running in snow in
mud in rain and they'd sing a song i'm a
marine
bring it on and the certainly go oh no
you know it's too muddy it's too
cold my legs hurt my knees hurt
and you see they told their mind i don't
want to do this and the mind said
stop when the marines told their mind i
want to do this i love this i love
running in cold and rain and they did it
many of my clients say you know i got a
speaking gig
and i was so terrified until you told me
the truth
your mind cannot tell the difference
between fear
and excitement instead of saying oh god
i'm so nervous i'm so excited i
want it i want it i want it i have
chosen it and chosen to feel great i
love speaking on stage i
love getting to my boss with ideas i
love
talking to potential customers i love
putting myself
out there and showing the world who i am
and what i have to say and you see it's
what i call
lie cheat and steal lie
to your mind cheat fear cheat
procrastination
steal back the phenomenal confidence you
were born with
no baby is born going oh i love this
crib so much i just stay here.
they can't wait to get out they're
little escape artists they're always
wriggling and running and jumping and
moving and when they go
hey mummy look at me in the pool look at
me on the slide look at me on the swing
go and sit at a children's park or
playground hang around at a pool
and there's all the good going hey look
at me look at me look at me
because they don't have procrastination
they don't have fear of rejection the
fear
of rejection is acquired procrastination
is acquired anyone trying to keep their
kid in bed on christmas morning
i would be shocked because they're
they're out of bed at 5 00 a.m because
they're so excited on their birthday
they're excited they don't know what
procrastination is and that's good news
for all of you because it means you
learnt it you acquired it and guess what
you can reactivate re-manifest
re-generate and recreate forever that
passion for life you were born with a
little kid that would jump in a puddle
and think it was exciting
go out in all kinds of weather and find
everything thrilling and exciting
be excited by storms and rain and sun
and snow
you can't keep little kids on the couch
they are balls of energy
and you were born with phenomenal
self-belief i want you to reactivate it
to re-manifest it to regenerate it now
by using those magic words
i have chosen this and
chosen to feel great about it i want
this so
if you're lying on the couch binge
watching a series
say i've chosen to switch this off
to apply myself to work and i've chosen
to feel great about it to feel really
really great about it rule number five
take accountability with simon sinek
in the 18th century
there was something that spread across
europe and eventually made its way to
america called
puerto fever also known as the black
death of child bed basically what was
happening
is women were giving birth and
they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of europe and it got worse
and worse and worse over the course of
over a century
in some hospitals it was as high as 70
percent
of women who gave birth who would die as
a result of giving birth
but this was the renaissance this was
the time of
empirical data and science and we had
thrown away
things like tradition and mysticism
these were men of science these were
doctors
and these doctors and men of science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses
of the of the women who had died and in
the morning
they would conduct autopsies and then in
the afternoon they would go and deliver
babies and finish their rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice
oliver wendell holmes realized that all
of these doctors were conducting
autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies
in the afternoon and he pointed it out
and said guys you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy
for 30 years until
finally somebody realized that if they
simply washed their hands
it would go away and that's exactly what
happened
when they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands
the black death of child bed disappeared
my point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new
men of science and empirical uh studiers
and
these men of finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your
actions you can take all the credit in
the world for the things that you do
right
as long as you also take responsibility
for the things you do wrong it must be a
balanced equation
you don't get it one way and not the
other you get to take credit
when you also take accountability rule
number six
overcome hesitation with jocko willing
shakespeare
between the acting of a dreadful thing
and the first motion all the interim
is like a fantasma or a hideous
dream
and that's brutus
from julius caesar and brutus in the
play
is plotting to kill caesar
someone he was loyal to
in shakespeare the master of
understanding human nature
he captures what that feels like
and here's what these lines mean between
the acting of a dreadful thing
so that's the moment that moment when
you're
waiting to do something that you don't
want to do
and the first motion so that's when you
actually start
doing that thing that you don't want to
do
all the interim now this is
all that time all that time in that
moment
while you are waiting to take action
is like a fantasma or a hideous
dream
so that moment that
moment when you're waiting to do
something it's like an
apparition a hideous dream a nightmare
and so the battle the struggle
it takes place in that moment
it's not knowing what to do
that's not the battle it's not actually
doing it
that's not the battle it's the moment in
between
it's the hesitation
hesitation is the enemy
and in war
understanding where the enemy is allows
you to defeat him
and this is where the enemy of action
the enemy of commitment the enemy of
change
that's where the enemy lies it lies
in the waiting
and all you have to do to win
is overcome that moment the waiting
the hesitation
all you have to do is go
move take action
get out of bed get your feet on the
ground
step into the gym put down the donut
pick up the kettlebell
do not hesitate do not wait go
forward go to war
and win at rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is implement rewards with andrew
hueberman reward incremental steps
in particular incremental steps that are
about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you
as you get better at things right the
stairs get further and further away from
one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take
the rungs on the ladder further apart so
to speak that's a time when
you really need to implement not only
the dopamine rewards but also
those serotonin and oxytocin rewards etc
so to make it actionable
i would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress
negative thoughts if you need trauma
therapy pursue that with a professional
but if you have negative thoughts just
remember i can also introduce
positive thoughts the same way i can
control running around the block
positive thoughts are the equivalent of
forward physical action
and if you reward them internally you
buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before
you are building a stronger version of
yourself completely between your own
ears and some people say well that's
silly it's like you're saying oh i'm
going to jump up and down reward myself
for doing nothing
no you're building the neural circuits
that reward
that you can control self-reward and in
doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently i don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push
you know my career is one that was made
over two decades it wasn't
we had our big you know peaks and we
added a lot of valleys
but learning to control these rewards is
absolutely key and i know you've done
this too
tom it's like you know it the huge wins
are great
but it's really about rewarding these
increments so you can keep going another
30 another 40 years 50 or 100 years if
that's how long
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign
says you have a 35 chance of actually
following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you every day
inside your head there is a war
being fought between growth you and
comfort you
every day every day you wake up you're
already fighting the war
you're already fighting the battle and
your goal your job your purpose your
mission
is to try to win more fights as growth
you
compare it to comfort you just think
about this morning
you got out of bed what is comfort you
want to do
comfort you wants to hit the snooze
button comfort you
wants five more minutes in the warm
blankets
comfort you says ah nobody really cares
if you show up today or not
just give just give yourself a break
take it easy
you did so much yesterday you know you
could start again on monday
that's that's the voice right like you
have your own version of it but that's
comfort you
telling you to be comfortable and
we love comfort you we love feeling like
we're
wrapped in a warm blanket and we have
hot chocolate and we just don't have to
do anything
because growth you requires doing scary
things
growth you requires doing something
bigger growth you get
requires stepping outside of your
comfort zone which comfort you
doesn't like but you're not happy
has comfort you you know it's a
different kind of happiness
it's a comfortable happiness but it's
not the
service happiness and you realize that
you want to serve that you're capable of
more
that you want to do big things that you
can do big things
you have a message that your story could
change people's lives you know this
i look at happiness as being split of
happiness being
the excitement versus fulfillment
or a momentary little shot
versus deep fulfillment
chasing comfort is that little shot
chasing comfort is having that chocolate
bar
tastes so good you know is the little
momentary
jolt where
growth you that's fulfillment
growth you is deep sustained long-term
happiness
and so you have to lean into growth you
more often than not
you getting up on time when you said you
would
and chasing after the day and whatever
you said you were gonna do if you work
out
you know first thing in the morning
that's part of your your goals to work
out right how many of you have
that goal work out first thing in the
morning okay great again
that decision is a fight between comfort
you and growth you
comfort you says oh my muscles are sore
you know i did such a good workout
yesterday my muscles are sore
so i'm gonna not do it today comfort you
says well you skipped yesterday's
workout so
whatever don't worry about this week we
start again next week
comfort you says well my gym is closed
right now so it can't go down
comfort you finds all the reasons why
you can't do it and growth you was
fighting to say
no we're doing this
we said we were going to do this we want
to look a certain way we want to hit a
certain weight we want our muscles to
build we want to have longevity no let's
go
wake up and do it and
what people don't realize is some people
think that it's
just some it's something it's something
rare
it's some kind of you know evan
carmichael or whoever it is
they're just different they're just
freaks it's not a one or zero thing
it's not a i'm living in growth mode all
the time
right i fight it every day i fight
comfort me versus growth me every day
even filming these videos i forgot to
bring my tripod
so at this time nina's shopping at
costco there's costco
she's getting some supplies for us for
the week
and i'm gonna make videos right used to
use the most of her time
and i usually bring my tripod and i have
not brought my tripod today
this is the last video of the film uh
and i'm holding
look this is what i'm doing here can i
show you here i i've got
my hand here this is my tripod and i've
got my leg crossed like this
and i'm resting my arm on my leg
right now on my knee because my arm is
about to fall off
i've been filming videos for two hours
my arm is about to fall off
i have no more strength in my left arm
i've been switching arms every now and
then
i got i got nothing left and going into
it like oh
i don't have my tripod okay now what i
mean do i
do do do we just go home and i get it
and then i'm delayed on making videos
do i just postpone it and say you know
what i'll make videos tomorrow
do i say you know whatever
nobody cares if i make videos or not
i'll just postpone it a week
that's all comfort evan talking
growth i was like no let's go we do
difficult things right
i do difficult things don't have a
tripod let's go
we're making anyway my arm will fall off
[Music]
super sore arm by tomorrow right
i fight it every day too i'm just like
you
i fight it every day too and your goal
is to wake up
and just try to win more fights as
growth you than comfort you
i don't win all the growth evan fights
most of the time i think we just default
to living
in comfort zone i think i've made
already a lot of decisions today based
off of comfort evan
not even recognizing that it's comfort
evan
we subconsciously live in our comfort
zone
and we find the reasons and
justifications to stay small and to stay
comfortable and stay safe and stay where
we are
most of the time it never bubbles up to
the conscious
[Music]
most of the time growth you never even
even has a fighting chance
you don't recognize that growth you is
losing the fight
because you've convinced yourself as to
why you should do it it's just
subconscious it's your autopilot
patterns
but it's when you catch it it's when you
catch it what do you do
when you catch it when when your arm is
tired because
because you don't have your tripod when
you don't want to get out of bed because
you had a rough night sleeping when you
don't want to work out because your
muscles are sore then what do you do
and it's in those moments that you start
to build and shift your identity
it's in those moments when you're
feeling tired and you still get up and
do it
it's in those moments when your muscles
are hurting and you still do a workout
it's in those moments when you don't
have your tripod and you still
film the videos it's in those moments
that you start to build self-love
you start to raise your standards a
little people talk about raising tenants
how do you do it that's how you do it
raising standards come from when you
would normally quit
you go one more when old you would say
that's enough
you do one more think of what we do in
life
as mapping out new terrain right so
think of the
think of our life as like the earth and
we're explorers right
and some people take one path they go to
work every day they do the same thing
same couple of friends they do and
that's and they're okay with this one
straight line path they don't see any of
the world
they just they do this they go do their
thing and they come back that's one
version
and there's some people who say this
this path that everybody says is great
this path that everybody like says this
is the security this is the safety this
is
how life is supposed to be it's like
screw that and they wander off the path
right if you're here with us today
you're here with me today you're part of
the inner circle um
that means that you're someone who's
wandered off the path
congratulations the path sucks the path
is what everybody else does the path
that
and if you're if somebody's on it and
they're miserable they want you to be on
the path with them when they see you
straight like no no get back on here
it's not safe out there
no it's not safe on the path we have one
life we got to squeeze every bit of
juice out of this life you don't want to
look back at the end of your life being
100 years old be in the hospital go wow
i walk the same path every day
i'm so glad i played it safe no screw
that no one says that [ __ ]
at the end you're like why didn't i step
off the path why didn't i go for more
why didn't i
tap into why did i go after being an
artist go after real estate investing go
after doing my own online business go
out to the fitness world go in the
coaching world
go sing why why didn't i do it because
someone told you staying on the path was
smart screw that get off the path
but if you think about that and you're
mapping out terrain so
just think if we're explorers if we're
on the path
we get to explore new territory i'm
going to read some of these guys
we get to explore new territory but when
you
explore new territory you've kind of
mapped out that terrain now if you go
off the path and you find a cliff
you can mark that if you find paradise
you could mark that
if you find water you mark that you find
mountains you mark that you find the
ocean you mark it
and all of a sudden you start exploring
for me
going through this process i mapped out
a whole new bunch of terrain
i'm not that i'm not listen can i tell
you something
i feel absolutely positively
bulletproof because i face the biggest
fear of my life there's nothing that can
get me let me just tell you something i
drive down the road and somebody cuts me
off i wave to him
i order chicken for dinner they bring me
steak well done i eat the steak well
done and say thank you
because the little [ __ ] doesn't matter
anymore if you if you want another level
of life get bigger problems and
solve bigger problems literally solve
bigger problems and watch your life go
to another level
watch the little [ __ ] fall away the
stuff that used to bug you be like why
did i let that bug me
get a deeper set of problems and solve
that and when you're done with that
solve the next one and when you're done
with that solve the next one instead of
solving hundred dollar problems you know
what my wish for you is
solve million dollar problems they're
the same amount of stress
if you need a hundred bucks to pay the
bill or you need a million i assure you
it's the same stress
so why not add more zeros people's
phones
are costing them their fortune
so how do i do it one of the rituals in
the book is the tight bubble of total
focus it's
it's based on edison's menlo park
there's a great documentary on what he
did but essentially
him and his band of co-geniuses
would leave the world go up to
this hill to menlo park where they could
get into
flow state to give credit where it's due
mihai chick sent me high f university of
chicago came up with that term
flow when we're at our absolute best
doing magical things in our performance
but that only comes when we get away
from the world so you can
play with your phone or you can be mono
maniacally focused on being a history
maker and legendary
you don't get to do both and so building
periods of time in that tight bubble of
total focus where
you leave your phone in another room
where you train your team or if you
don't have a team you just don't have
any distractions
and you ask yourself what is the one
thing i could do
that would allow me to go out in the
world and
and bring my magic to the world the
human brain
has a phenomenon called transient
hypofrontality the neocortex
as you know it's the the seed of
thinking it's our monkey mind it's all
the chattering it's the stuff that says
tom you can't do it robin you can't do
it what would they think
what if i fail what if i get laughed at
that's all the neocortex it's the crown
jewel of brain development
not a primitive brain crown jewel
there's no genius in there and here's
what i mean when we
get away from distraction and we find
our menlo park or
we go work in a quiet place and we get
lost
the neocortex actually shuts down and
that's why it's called transient hypo
frontality for a short period of time
our thinking
shuts down the whole model is in the
book
and we actually go from brainwaves at
beta
down to alpha down to theta and maybe
even delta
and we stopped thinking we go into flow
in other words
the advanced minds of the world the
great geniuses
galileo da vinci steve jobs
they weren't in the neocortex they got
away
from the world for bursts of time which
allowed them to access the human
capability we all have to get into flow
state
and access insights that they went out
in the world and then
executed on with a world-class team
which totally changed the game
people are trying to replicate my model
but are overspending on the tech
or the lighting or the post-production
like you know
that's not going to work if you're
running a motorboat
you don't feel it the same way you fill
a cruise ship it's going to sink and
that's what people are doing
they're overthinking and then that then
led to the next part which is don't
overthink your content
because that wasn't the physical
manifestation it was the mental
manifestation
you know you know many owners and ceos
jump in and look at their instagram
account and like i don't like that
picture and it like breaks the whole
machine
like that's you know so like all these
things you know what a tortoise will
withdraw its limbs when it feels
intimidated when it feels insecure when
it feels
fearful of being attacked but when the
tortoise finds itself in a surrounding
which is protected and secure
the tortoise will bring all of its limbs
out
i think even in our relationships when
we feel the fear of being judged
the fear of being used the fear of being
rejected we withdraw ourselves from
people in our relationships don't we
but when we feel protected when we feel
secure
when we feel ourselves in a surrounding
in an environment where there is
trust whether it's understanding where
we are treated with respect when we're
treated with love
that's when we bring ourselves fully out
to connect to that person
we're happy confiding to them we're
happy to speak to them
they're happy to deeply connect with
them and i think that's really what
makes a
relationship really meaningful and happy
isn't it so yes a tortoise does teach us
that we should look for those people in
our relationships who can give us that
surrounding
that we can bring out most of our the
best best art of us
and uh we should try and avoid those
surroundings where
we feel fearful of being judged
you know and being used in which case we
need to withdraw like the tortoise
withdraws its limbs within its shell
next up
is your daily g3 journal and review
uh if you've heard me teach a lot about
down times
before uh especially the last couple
years a couple years ago
the the g3 was the three g's and it's
what it means is
every single day i want you to journal
on these three
things and i do mean journal meaning you
write it down
in the morning and you review it at
night
so you're that's why it says journal and
review so you write in the morning
and review it all at night and so here's
what the g3 is the first thing you know
is
your gratitude and that is just what are
you grateful for
why does that make you feel good why are
you thankful for it
and just write it down in your journal
just a whole like you should have a
gratitude journal already
but when you're disappointed or having
setbacks i want you to do the gratitude
in the morning
a lot of graduate journal stuff is it
tonight i want you to move it right up
in the morning like just
you got to prime your morning for some
goodness so right off the bat
you got to do that okay so gratitude
second major thing i want you to focus
on
is your goals what are the specific
daily and weekly goals you're working on
you got to get really narrow focused
right when you're disappointed or sad or
set back
uh you know the idea of creating a
vision board
and seeing out ten years from now that's
too much what you need to do
is get really close in your term this
day's goals
this week's goals because you can check
those suckers off
and get a little progress in you'll feel
differently as we talk about
so goals is important and the third g
is goodness and the goodness is
noticing what is good from the previous
day
so when you start the day you're like
okay what am i grateful for in general
for life what are my goals specifically
daily and weekly
in each of these different areas of my
life you might have goals in your career
and your health in your finances and
your relationships
and then the goodness is what actually
good did happen
yesterday and that will just get you in
a place where you're like oh
this day is going to be good too it's
making you more mindful to all the good
things and the reason i do that one
last and the difference between
gratitude gratitude is general things
you're grateful for
the goodness thing is to think about
what good happened yesterday
and the reason we do that because in
neuroscience we know that thinking about
the goodness from yesterday
is triggering your hippocampus to kind
of turn on and fire up
and if we get more memory activation off
the bat
in the morning we actually have more
creativity in the day too
it's weird sparking memory is good for
creativity
creativity is very good for coping and
so
that's why i'm trying to get you to
reflect a little bit on something that
happened
yesterday just to think through find
that mindful moment
and it's also teaching you to be more
mindful as through of the moments each
day
not just grateful in general but
actually being mindful for the good
moments
each day so i want you to do that
journal every morning and then
every night i want you to look back at
it
and think about it and maybe repeat it
if you want to
i just want you to review the day and
review
those things what was i grateful for oh
yeah that's right
because maybe at the end of the day the
truth is you haven't moved a lot forward
maybe you know your your spouse or
yourself you're still sick
or maybe there's still conflict or maybe
the business still because
i'm not going to be pollyannish and say
everything changes in one day and
everything's great just because you did
your gratitude journal
you might be there today it still sucks
so reviewing it
is going to put you back in that
positive mindset that's going to help
you
then take the next day you're always
talking to yourself about the same stuff
right and you've got the same hooks and
the same triggers and the same hang-ups
and the same
i mean you got to try on the idea that
you're constantly listening for
and looking for evidence
that your subconscious view of
everything is accurate
in the background to your mind it's
these
little triggers in paul yeah i need to
remember to do that and i have to
and i can't do that one i'm not going to
do this and then she said my stupid
so the whole noise in the background is
shaping
a certain view of the world if you like
so that noise um
you have to start checking and on that
like what am i saying to myself what is
that based on
why did i tell myself no there instead
of yes there
to me that growing sense of awareness of
your own
automatic of the of you as i call it
that little voice in your head
yeah the more you get which is usually
not a really smart little
no and it's kind of like an idiot right
i mean
we would love to i'd love to wake up in
the morning in my little voices like
you're amazing
yeah but it never does no nothing it
goes oh [ __ ] here we go again
yeah it's the same noise in your head
um but it's not and it's not um
some kind of accident that noise it's
designed to equip you to survive in a
world
but the problem is you're surviving
stuff that you just don't need to
survive
you shouldn't survive your job you're
not supposed to survive your marriage
you're not supposed to survive your body
but we end up with these mechanisms that
were in this kind of internal war
and so i you know i want people to do
the right kind of work on themselves
in a way that makes sense to them
there's a lot of research on what's
called the theory of narrative identity
your narrative is what you say about
yourself it's how you define yourself
that's your identity your identity is
way more important than your personality
your personality is surface level
your personality is external your
identity is internal your personality is
the byproduct
your identity is the cause so however
you see and describe yourself whatever
you affirm of yourself and by the way
everything you say
is an affirmation if you say it's gonna
be a bad day that's an affirmation if
you say it's gonna be a great day that's
an affirmation
if you say this video sucks that's an
affirmation if you say this video is
great that's an affirmation
everything you say is an affirmation of
something and everything you say about
yourself
is also an affirmation of who you are
and here's what the research actually
says
in psychology the research and this is
from daniel gilbert from harvard but
there's so many other
researchers on this your future self
is going to be a different person than
who you are today you actually
underestimate how different you're going
to be in the future
just like probably your former self is
more different than you than you
actually give yourself credit for
think about who you really were 10 years
ago think about what mattered to you
think about how you spent your time
think about what you cared about
chances are you've got different values
different priorities different focus
different goals
and so that actually brings up the point
well where does your identity come from
your identity actually comes from your
goals it comes from what you're trying
to accomplish it comes from
what you value and so what is it you're
trying to accomplish in your life right
now is it finishing that degree
is it paying the bills is it writing
that book is it becoming
whatever it is you're seeking whatever
it is you're trying to do whatever
outcomes you're trying to produce
that's what's ultimately framing your
identity and your identity shapes your
behavior and your behavior over time
becomes
your personality so here's the quote
it's from albert einstein imagination is
more important than knowledge
for knowledge is limited whereas
imagination embraces the entire world
stimulating progress giving birth to
evolution so this is another thing that
daniel gilbert found in his research
is that most people they don't imagine a
future self in fact most people think
that their future self is basically the
same person they are today
as daniel gilbert said human beings are
works in progress that mistakenly think
they're finished
so if you think that your future self is
the exact same person you are today then
you think you're a work
in progress that's you actually don't
think you're a work in progress you
think you're finished
and that's what carol dweck calls a
fixed mindset if you think that who you
are right now is who you're always going
to be
then you don't have that much
imagination towards your future self if
you don't have that much imagination
towards your future self
you're not conceived you know again back
to the napoleon hill quote whatever the
mind can conceive and believe the mind
can achieve
if you view your future self as a
different person which by the way they
are your future self is going to be in a
different situation they're going to
have different goals different values
they're gonna be in a different world
even think about how different the world
is right now versus where it was five
ten years ago
we are part of a culture and our values
in many ways are shaped by that culture
we're slow boiling into our future
selves just like the culture is slow
boiling into whatever it's slow boiling
into
so you're slow boiling into someone
you're going to be different in 10 years
from now
the question is are you going to live by
design and intention or are you just
going to
fade based on whatever culture takes you
social norms society leans heavily on us
all
so uh if you they're just broad examples
of this
so pressure religious pressure media
pressure
all kinds of peer pressure yes um
let's say so just some broad examples uh
you walk into an elevator and you turn
around to face the front
you have a job interview and you wear a
suit and tie or a dress or something
nice
there's no reason it has to be that way
right like you could face the back of
the elevator
you could wear a swimsuit to a job
interview but you don't do that
because it violates the shared norms of
the group right it violates the shared
expectations of what that society has
but that's not that's true not only in a
broad sense
that we're part of these tribes like big
tribes you know what it means to be a
christian or to be american or to be
australian or whatever but it's also
true in the small tribes that we belong
to what it means to be
a neighbor on this street or a member of
your local crossfit gym
or to volunteer for a local organization
all of those tribes all those groups
that you belong to
have a set of shared expectations a set
of shared norms
and the key if you want to build habits
that last if you want to change the way
that you
interpret cues is to join a group where
your
the desired behavior is the normal
behavior right
like there are there are plenty of
people who
they want to work out but going to the
gym feels like a lot to them
it feels hard feels like a sacrifice but
there are also people who go to the gym
every week and it's just normal it
doesn't feel like an obligation that's
the desire behavior is the normal
behavior their lifestyle right
same thing for uh musicians you know
like if you want to learn an instrument
hang out with people who play all the
time you know like if you hang out with
a bunch of musicians it's like well
yeah we do all yeah we play four days a
week if we play seven days a week
because it just happens that's that's
what the tribe does
the caveat to this and the thing that i
don't see people mention a lot
is that the reason social norms
influence our behavior so much
is because we want to belong to the
tribe we want to be friends with those
people
and so we don't want to lose the
friendship or lose belonging
over violating the norms you're not
going to hang out with a bunch of vegans
and have pork right and just like be the
only one eating that you won't hang out
with them for very long because they're
not going to be friends with them
anymore
they'll kick you out so you want to rise
to the standard of that group of that
community so the key i think
is to join a group where your desired
behavior is a normal behavior
and you already have something else in
common with that group
so steve cam is a good example of this
so like steve runs nerd fitness
right and all these people want to get
in shape who are coming into his
community
but they also love star wars or batman
or spider-man or you know all these
other things that nerds are into
and if you show up it can be
intimidating to want to get in shape or
you know work out the first time but if
you can connect with the group
over your mutual love of star wars then
you're like oh well i'm friends with
these people and now i also want to pick
up those other habits of them because i
want to belong with the group because
we're already friends
and so i think you can apply that
methodology to most
new tribes that you join don't just join
a new tribe because they have the
desired behavior also try to find a way
that you can overlap with them find some
shared context some other stuff too yeah
that you can bond over
and then it's easier to adopt habits
musicians that like to be healthy
yeah if you want to do both right
finding that even subgroup it's like hey
we love you know we love playing music
and then also you're going to start
eating better because we all want to eat
healthy
i was a very driven competitive tennis
player
growing up yeah i started playing at age
10
by age 15 as one of the best players in
the state in the country
i lived in attendance academy i moved
away from my family to train
so i would only go to school for part
time during the day i went to college on
tennis scholarship
and then my sophomore year i had a
really bad injury to my achilles tendon
and i was in crutches and a full leg
cast and that
is when i actually had my first
entrepreneurial idea
the funny thing is i didn't even know
what the word entrepreneur meant
my dad was a doctor my grandfather's a
doctor there were no entrepreneurs
you know at that time really in my
family but
um i couldn't carry my laundry down to
the facility
because of the crutches and so i looked
in the yellow pages which some listeners
won't know what that is
um but uh i looked in the yellow pages
the early google
and uh there was no one that would pick
up and deliver my laundry and so my
roommate
his dad was an entrepreneur and we were
telling him about this problem he said
you guys should start a laundry business
and so next thing you know we bought
like an old fedex truck for
1500 bucks set up shop started doing
people's laundry
i never went back to playing tennis and
i dropped out of college and
and that was the beginning of my
entrepreneur path but so much of
what i think has made me a successful
entrepreneur
is that self-reliance because tennis is
an individual sport you don't have a
team to
count on the self-discipline that i had
to be training so hard at such a young
age
the sacrifices i made you know i wasn't
out drinking beer with people on friday
night
because i had matches saturday morning
so i really
i love to hire athletes for that reason
you know i love to hire athletes and i
love to hire military
me too because they're unbelievable in
terms of their discipline and their
focus
um and that was who i was before
becoming an entrepreneur
when you're taking if you were to write
your name first and last on a piece of
paper actually you could do it right now
first and last and everyone encourages
you to just to do this
or imagine you're writing your name
first and last on a piece of paper
and then when you're done i want you to
switch hands and in your opposite hand
right below it write your first and last
name with your opposition i don't even
know if i could take me ten minutes
and so while people are doing it you'll
notice when you're doing it with the
opposite hand
as we're doing it that's actually pretty
good
that if i was to ask you which one is
the which one was easier first or second
and you would say the first was easier
which one is is
uh more comfortable first or last the
first one the first one so not only was
it faster it was easier
and then which one was higher quality
let's check that out this the
personally the first one hopefully the
person is higher quality also as well
and so here's the thing that means the
second time
it took longer the second time it also
was not as comfortable and the second
time also the quality wasn't quite as
good
and here's the thing what i'm saying
it's how you learn
some people are trying to learn
something with the opposite hand
so it takes longer it feels weird and
the quality is not quite as good as
opposed to if you're using your dominant
hand
how do we know how to learn with our
dominant hand as opposed to the opposite
hand yeah and that's a metaphor for how
we like to take in
information some people like to learn by
reading some people they just cannot get
through a book though they have to
listen to that audio
or that podcast other people or watch
someone lecturing it or talking
exactly and so we all have different
styles and it's not right or wrong
now we can actually improve our ability
to read we actually can improve our
ability to listen and apply
so if there are areas where we feel weak
you know this book is a guide
guide book to be able to level up those
areas so you could be more of a whole
brain learner also as well
but really when it comes to accelerated
learning it's not again how smart you
are
it's how are you smart and that honors
us and it takes the judgment out
sometimes in school
it's like the top ten percent get a's
another 10 get b's
and then 80 percent were like you and i
it's like it's like we're
it's like we're failing school as
opposed to the way school
maybe is failing us because school
teaches you what to learn
what to focus on what to think what to
remember
but not how to learn and how to think
what teaches you how to
think and learn in one way exactly
exactly and when i talk about in the
book i talk about
the the the four super villains that are
holding you back in your work
in your schooling in your life is driven
by technology but one of them
is digital deduction where we're where
we're depending on technology to tell us
what to think we're not even using the
children right now
they're finding that their reasoning
abilities their ability to analyze
critical thinking is not as sharp as
where it should be
because because of technology because
technology is doing the thinking for us
and our mind i'm going to say this
repeatedly is like a muscle it's use it
or lose it and just like when you go you
have your personal trainer to make your
muscles stronger
more energized more flexible more
pliable
you know more you want your mental
muscles to be
stronger more energized more pliable
more more flexible of course
and so many people refer to me as a
brain coach because what i do is i train
your brain
because i think we're in the millennium
of the mind and it's really about mental
fitness
our ability to adapt our ability to
think our ability to solve
problems and this really is everything
when people see me wearing
brain shirts all the time or pointing to
my brain
the reason why i do that is because what
you see you take care of
you see your hair you take care of your
hair you see your skin you take care of
your skin you see your clothing take
care of your clothing you don't see your
brain
exactly and that controls everything
and so when i point to the brain or how
honored with their shirts just like
people have their emotions on their
sleeve you know i have my brain on my
chest
because i want to put it forefront to
remind people to love their brain where
do i go from there i
i really recognize the power of going
deeper which is instead of just
transforming somebody's sort of meat
suit
transform who they are what's their idea
of themselves
that that was what really then just lit
a fire under my butt because i
i can remember i was a ski instructor
for a minute too and um i had these two
guys
such a powerful memory who had the same
experience skiing
they were you know just beyond beginner
sort of intermediate
um they had about the same athleticism
in terms of their size
and they were about the same age but i
can remember one coming down
it wasn't like a crazy slope it wasn't
like a double black or anything like
that but he was so
um apprehensive but the other guy just
kind of went for it more like a child
like he wasn't concerned about what
could happen so when
at that point i was always got nothing
to do with their resources right their
equipment their experience
it had everything to do with how their
the future occurred to them
it was all about mindset and that really
was one of those moments where i
realized that the thing that's really
driving everybody's life
is your perspective and so i was like
wow
if i could help people shift perspective
that then
completely shifts their life versus most
people are trying to change the
circumstances of their life
right trying to change the mountain yeah
which is exhausting futile and at the
end of the day it's a perpetual
sort of journey that never gets
fulfilled right because it's sort of
there's always something else to fix but
right
for me where i got to is that point
where i realized there was nothing
external that was really
the source of the the author of my
experience it was all
how i was relating to it it was all in
the way that i
interacted with life that created my
experience i've been a note card
taker carrier for as long as i can
remember
though this leather one which i got from
the company
uh i think they're called levenger they
make like bags and stuff
i've had this one for about 10 years so
i use
3x5 cue cards and they
all have different colors to do
different things now
my daily list is the first card so these
are the things that i
want to do today and
truthfully i don't always get everything
done on my today card
um probably two-thirds of the time
i do go to bed with everything on the
daily card done
but if not um you will flip it over
and then the next day take something
there if it's still relevant and put it
on that card along with the next things
that need to be done
i then have and by the way i sometimes
use a white card or a green
it's either white or green is always my
daily card
my pink card is my number two card and
you can see that
this was last week so i'm like a car i'm
cheap with these things so it's like i
i just love the fact that i'm saving
money by using both sides of it
so for this week's pink card um
i have all of the things that have to be
done by
sunday so every week i redo the pink
card
and um as you can see for all of my
things there's like a little square box
and it says next to the thing so a lot
of the times it'll be
a box with a half check through it which
is when i'm partially done with that
task so the task is fully done when you
have the two
checks through the box so i have boxes
here that have
nothing i haven't done them yet i have
others that have a single
hash through which means it's in
progress and i have others that are
fully
hashed through which means they're
they're all the way done
um i then have my orange card which is
um it's a very it's a notice this one to
get this color of orange it has to come
on this awful
chartreuse stripey color on the back
which i don't reuse
this is very patient specific so i speak
spanish
so i have a very a very patient specific
group of things that go on here
the white card which is different from
the white card that i lead with because
it sits far enough back in the pack it
never gets confused
has all of my long term sort of
just random personal things that i don't
want to cloud
on my weekly list although
intermittently things from here will go
on the weekly list
so again i don't want to read these
things because they won't make any sense
to you but it's
it's just a bunch of stuff like oh you
got to fix the autoresponder in your
email
and oh i got to return my range finder
because it's not working very well
and oh i need to sync the way this thing
works with that thing
it might take me two months to get
through this list
and that's fine because you know
intermittently things from this list
will make it onto the weekly pink list
and obviously things from the weekly
pink list intermittently make it onto
the green list um
unrelated my last card is just a place
where i keep track of
stupid things that i like to do so i
don't even know why i carry this i think
tim ferriss once
asked me to make a list of all the dumb
things i do
and i started carrying this list around
which has like egg boxing tearing phone
books counting forks and knives
doing my tsa voice playing the what-if
game
and pretending to be in a little bit of
a rush and every time i think of another
dumb thing i like to do
it goes on that list so that is the card
carrying system obviously highly
modifiable
you can do anything you want that's the
beauty of the card system
my mission in life has been and still is
is to to give people a vision of
themselves beyond their mental
conditioning and their circumstances
to let them know that they have
greatness within them but han
greatness it's not our destiny it's a
choice that you have to make every day
you have to put yourself in a state of
perpetual
discomfort in order to manifest your
greatness you've got to reach outside of
your comfort zone
so every day i look forward to the
opportunity
to inspire people to reach higher to
understand and know that what they have
done is only a tip of the iceberg of
what's possible for them
the antidote joan baez says that my
coach susie carter
first shared this with me that joan baez
says
the antidote for despair is action
so i said how can i be an action i was
always looking to be an action
what else can i do what else can i do
what else can i do and then i go learn
what else can i do so to me
there's a very short line between
learning and doing yes
and if you haven't done anything what
you learned why are you getting more
education
you haven't even implied what you like
i'm a hell of a coach now
it's like people who read a book and
they don't go apply it they just want to
read the next book right
hi the book i read when i was in my
deepest darkest hour stephen covey seven
habits of highly effective people
changed my life because i got into
radical action behind it
i was like oh oh stephen covey talks
about
attending your own funeral doing a
visionary session where you attend your
own funeral
and there are four people to speak what
were those four people say about you
what kind of brother were you what kind
of friend were you what kind of social
change agent were you
what kind of neighbor were you man when
i did that exercise i was like
oh i'm a nice person but i i'm not
getting the
they're not they're not saying the
things about me that i want to be saying
right yes
i'm writing my eulogy right now i'm
writing my eulogy
i'm writing my i'm writing my legacy i'm
not just living for now
i'm living for the 40 year 40 years from
now story being told about me
i'm living for my grandchildren's
grandchildren's grandchildren's story
about who great-great-great-grandma was
and when you live for a lifetime
not just your life cycle but a lifetime
you live for the legacy i'm writing my
legacy now
you won't sweat the small stuff anymore
you won't get caught up in gossip
you won't get caught up in and living
inside worry you might worry
but worry does not have worry does not
have permission
to take up real estate in your body
worry
is chased by solution and strategy yes
by action
yeah and i always tell people listen
i'll have every emotion like everyone
else
i'll have fear i have doubt i have
judgment but you cannot take up real
estate my body there's no lease options
to buy
in my mind don't lease option by my mind
and don't take up real estate i got
things to do i got i got changes to make
and i'm not a super shiro
i'm not i'm an ordinary woman i'm an
ordinary woman
who chooses every day to make one more
extraordinary decision
sandy gallagher is my business partner
love her
she is really good she was going through
a very tough time personally
a number of years ago we were in phoenix
we were doing a seminar
i had to leave catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave could we
get together maybe for a cup of coffee
could you um i want to talk to you and i
said sure
so we went across the road to a coffee
shop and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this
i said sure i didn't know what i was
going to tell her but i knew i'd tell
her something
so i said every day i want you
to take a pen and write down
every morning write down 10 things
you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it
you're really grateful
then i want you to send love
to three people that are bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them they've got nothing to do with it
you're thinking bad thoughts about them
you're putting yourself in a bad
vibration
send love to three people that bother
you
and then take five minutes
and be quiet just be perfectly quiet
and ask for guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day she started to do it like that
everything changed
in fact my assistant gina who's been
with me over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
gina i told her what i wanted
within an hour she had a pad printed at
kinko's
and had it the ten things
one down to ten you know send love to
three people and bother you be quiet for
five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii with her
sister and her mother the next day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that
it changed every one of their lives we
give that out now
in a lot of our seminars and we train
the audience to do it
start every morning write ten things
that you're grateful for
send love to three people who bother you
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
[Music]
if you want to learn how to make any new
habit stick with john assaraf check out
the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there when we talk
about how do we create
rituals or how do we change habits um
that last the first thing is to have a
different expectation